let me start by saying right from the
get-go how much I loved this movie you
did a phenomenal job one of my favorites
of the year thank you um I loved the way
you shot this film you and Robbie
collaborated just the the fish I the
fish lens the choice of lenses the
everything I loved it talked a little
bit but collaborating with Robbie on the
look at the film for my last film few
films I think I've been experimenting
with certain things movement lensing
camera angles and things like that so I
felt that this film was an opportunity
to take things even further and also a
good opportunity to work with Robbie
that I had met a few times and we were
always discussing about working together
at some point I really loved his work so
yeah there were some initial ideas that
I had coming into the film I really
wanted to enhance the feel of those
extremely big spaces and how they how
they're juxtaposed to the few people
that inhabit them so the use of you know
extreme wide-angle lenses kind of
enhanced that feel and it created those
huge distorted spaces and it also at the
same time made the film feel quite
claustrophobic because you kind of see
where the space ends and it's not
infinite although it's big we discussed
a lot about camera movement and we
wanted to have within the same shot more
than one of the characters so there was
a lot of movement and panning and
[Music]
another thing is that I always like to
work with natural light or practical
lighting so in in our case you know
there was no electricity during that
period so we had to work with either
daylight or candles which was exciting
and kind of scary at the same time but
yeah Robby's really up for trying
anything and going anyplace you direct
him to and it was a great experience we
started a show on collider called for
your consideration
and one of the things we've been talking
about with everyone recently is what
does it mean to be an Oscar movie
especially with the changing like a lot
more Academy members now and the
diversity the fact that more films are
being thought of it's not just a certain
time type of movie what does it mean for
you to be quote-unquote with an Oscar
movie I mean I have no idea to know you
know how it is define there who makes
the decision that a film is an Oscar
movie I never think about these things
before it actually happens I just try to
do you know the best that I can with the
film and then if people appreciate it
and in somehow it ends up being
characterized as an Oscar film or an
award worthy film or anything like that
it's always you know a huge positive for
the film I'm always obsessed with
talking about the editing process
because that's the final rewrite I'm
curious maybe what did you learn from
any friends and family screenings or any
test screenings that impacted the
finished film when I show the film in
general what I've realized is that I
it's not so much how people reacted or
what they say about it when they
intellectualize it but it's mostly how I
feel while I'm showing it to them so if
I feel comfortable in certain parts of
the film I know that it's working if I
feel uncomfortable that other people are
watching that part of the film I know
that you know that something different
needs to be done there it's all about
you know putting yourself
in a position where you're exposed
you're exposing your work to other
people and then you you realize how you
feel about it the film is a lot funnier
than I think people might think it is I
mean last night I was laughing many
times and same with the audience could
you sort of talk about the humor there's
a there's a lot of really great humor in
the film yeah I think from the beginning
when we when we started developing the
screenplay I knew that I wanted it to be
a quite a funny humorous film like a
tragic comedy in a sense so it was it's
always the case that you're trying to
strike a balance between the comedy and
the drama and the ridiculousness of
situations and people and characters and
you know the darkness of the story as
well so yeah I guess this film might
might have more of a funny aspect to it
then you know some of my other films but
the darkness comes as well Oh 100% sir I
say again one of the best films of the
year thank you thank you so much for
your time
you